if you're looking for ways to develop a
success mindset work smarter and dream
big in this video is for you
success is not an action it's a way of
life if you want to accomplish great
things
greatness must be reflected in
everything that you do high achievers
always set challenging goals and
continue to work toward them in
everything they do by knowing how to
prioritize tasks and working from a list
you increase your productivity and
output by 25 to 50 percent each day need
motivation watch a top 10 believe nation
what's happened time in my one word is
believe and I believe in you I believe
you have an amazing gift inside you that
I want to see exploded to the world so
let's get your motivation to attend and
get you believing in you grab a snack
and chew in today's lessons from a man
who has spoken to over five million
people and over five thousand events
around the world about personal and
professional development is Brian Tracy
and here's my take on his top ten
boroughs a success vol 3 enjoy
alright let's kick things off with rule
number one love what you do one of the
most important elements of successful
entrepreneurship is loving what you do
this means not just a love for doing
business but also a passion for your
specific field not only does loving your
work make it easier to carry out your
daily duties but they can make those
actions seem like they aren't even
duties at all you're likely to spend
your free time brushing up your skills
or thinking of ways to attract more
clients those who love what they do are
also more likely to deal with failure
constructively learning how to do better
rather than getting discouraged rule
number two is develop a success mindset
success is not an action it's a way of
life if you want to accomplish great
things
greatness must be reflected in
everything that you do thus regardless
of what it is that you want to
accomplish the path to success must
begin by adopting the right mindset the
first step to building a mindset for
success is to define what it means to
succeed setting goals for yourself makes
it easier to come up with a plan of
action to achieve your ambitions
and will motivate you to carry out that
plan it also gives you a standard
against which to measure your progress
and adjust your strategy you should thus
define your life or career goals and
then think about what you need to do
every day to achieve them in addition
create short-term goals each day or week
making sure to align them with your
broader aims and bigger goals rule
number 3 stop killing time you can
increase your productivity and move
closer towards your goals just by
managing what you are doing and when you
are doing it so why then do people
choose to kill time this is quite
literally letting time
pass you by instead of taking advantage
of it telling time is a vicious cycle
what starts as a short break browsing
online can turn into hours wasted it
feeds your lack of action and interrupts
your workflow when you find yourself in
one of these situations scrolling the
internet aimlessly
stop for a second and think about what
you aren't accomplishing the more you
procrastinate the longer it will take
for your task to really get done
sometimes a task seems so daunting you
don't want to get started you come up
with a random thing or things to do
wasting your time instead of knocking
this one task out I've been there too in
my book eat that frog I talk about
eating your ugliest frog first tackle
the hardest thing on your to-do list or
the thing that is hanging over your head
and get it done first it takes
discipline to accomplish the hardest
task first but it is a habit that will
increase your levels of performance and
productivity sometimes you have to
ignore how you feel and just get started
nobody wants to start a difficult task
but successful people put their heads
down and just do it
rule number four take productive actions
effective entrepreneurs spend every
moment of their time taking productive
actions they constantly look for
opportunities to enhance their business
and act decisively whenever they find an
opportunity constant action doesn't mean
deciding without thinking careful
thought after all is a necessary action
in business what it means is remaining
productive at all times so that all you
do contributes to your goals rule number
five dream big
high achievers always set challenging
goals and continue to work toward them
in everything they do self-made
millionaires all started with a dream
and one of their secrets is dreaming
big you can then practice back from the
future thinking you project forward five
years and allow yourself to imagine the
amount of money you'd like to earn and
have it your bank account then work back
from the future to the present make a
list of the logical steps in order that
you need to take to get from where you
are to where you want to be then figure
out what big or small action you can
take today rule number six is work
smarter when it comes to making your
daily to-do list make sure that you're
working from the 80/20 rule if you have
ten items to do on your list two of them
will be more important than the other H
put together you can do this by asking
yourself if I were to be called out of
town for a month what is the top twenty
percent of my tasks that I must
accomplish today by knowing how to
prioritize tasks and working from a list
you increase your productivity and
output by twenty five to fifty percent
each day after you've made your
effective to-do list make sure that you
create time blocks dedicated to each
task keep in mind that new tasks and
responsibilities will come up
continually phone calls will come in
emails will need to be dealt with and
meetings will need to happen the key to
working smarter is also setting aside
chunks of time for those unexpected
tasks that will come up scheduling your
time this way reduces stress and makes
you feel in charge of your life rule
number seven be flexible as important as
it is to make plans commitment to a long
term vision or strategy should not come
at the expense of flexibility sooner or
later something will happen that you did
not expect and you'll have to respond to
it without hesitating a successful
entrepreneur is able to adjust their
plans
when they proved impractical and quickly
making the changes necessary to deal
with any new development rule number
eight clarify your true values most
people don't realize that reaching your
financial goals starts with your core
values you must do well in all areas of
your life and determine what it is that
you believe in and stand for in order to
find true financial success your values
align at the very core of everything you
are as a human being the virtues and
qualities that you stand for are what
constitute the person you have become
and will continue becoming so all
improvement in your life including
financial improvement begins with you
clarifying your true values committing
yourself to living consistently with
them and then aligning everything you do
with them when you align your work in
personal life to support your financial
goals you'll find it much easier to
reach them or any goal that you set
rule number 9 evaluate your competition
it's easy to assess the weaknesses of
your opponent things you might do better
than them it's much more beneficial
however to put your pride aside and make
note of what their strengths are
how are your competitors assets a
superior to their companies what do they
do well where do you fall short in
comparison gain insight on their
capabilities and strategies to get there
implement the same strategies or adapt
them to fit your own circumstances
self-knowledge and evaluating your
opponent's gives you a competitive edge
above your peers and rule number 10 the
last one before the bonuses have
integrity
having honesty and integrity in the
workplace is one of the most important
qualities of great leadership in
business and I'm going to tell you why
whenever I hold a strategic planning
session the first value that all the
executives agree on is integrity leaders
know that honesty and integrity are the
foundations of leadership leaders stand
up for what they believe in for example
Jon Huntsman
senior is a multi-billionaire who
started a chemical company from scratch
and grew it into a 12 billion dollar
enterprise his book winners never cheat
is filled with stories taken from his
own experience in which he steadfastly
refused to compromise his principles
Huntsman says that integrity is the
reason why he has been as successful as
he is there are no moral shortcuts in
the game of business of life he writes
there are basically three kinds of
people the unsuccessful the temporarily
successful and those who become and
remain successful over the months and
years the difference is character there
are many examples of temporary winners
who won by cheating for a number of
years Enron was cited as one of
America's most innovative and daring
companies the CEO of the company knew
the most important people in the country
including the President of the United
States except that an Ron's success was
built on lies and the winners who headed
the company are now case studies in a
lack of integrity leaders with integrity
may not be the most famous or flashy of
leaders and they don't care integrity
means doing the right thing because it
is the right thing to do and that's what
makes success
now I've got some special Brian Tracy
bonus rules for you but before we get
into those I have a question of the day
which is where are you killing time
Brian Tracy is huge on productivity and
making the most of every single day
where are you wasting time in your life
in your business leave it down the
comments below I'm really excited to
find out thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one where it
is much love I'll see you soon and enjoy
the bonuses
your ability to stay positive and
maintain positive thoughts determines
the tone of your emotional life the
words you use to describe what is
happening to you and to discuss how you
feel about external events triggers the
emotions of happiness or unhappiness
that you experience when you see things
positively and constructively and look
for the good in each situation and each
person you have a tendency to remain
naturally cheerful and optimistic since
the quality of your overall life is
determined by how you feel
moment the moment one of your most
important goals should be to use
positive affirmations and every other
psychological technique available to
keep yourself thinking and talking about
what you want and to keep your mind off
of what you don't want or what you fear
one of the things I've learned over the
years is that people may have tremendous
potential but because of the way they
are perceived by others the way other
people look at and value think and talk
about them they never get a chance to
use that potential so I began to study
what it is about branding an image that
sets you up to be successful and far
faster than most other people let me
define a brand first a brand is
basically a promise when you have a
brand it's a promise that you make and
are known for keeping to the person who
you are asking or trying to influence
human beings decide emotionally and
justify logically if you have a good
personal brand people aren't willing to
pay you more for your product or service
and argue less a brand always begins
with your values what do you stand for
quality of excellence responsiveness
teamwork innovation leadership then when
you're clear about these you build a
tremendous personal brand by starting
with the principle of integrity
there's no better reputation you can
have other than for people to say that
when they do business with you you
always fulfill your promises the answer
for success is to do what you've been
hired to do and do it now this expands
into every area of your interactions
with others here's the rule everything
counts everything that you do either
creates and builds your brand or weakens
and destroys your brand everything
counts in a busy world it's very easy to
feel as if you are unhappy or
unfulfilled
maybe you feel as if you do not have
enough money or your relationships are
not where you want them to be you may
easily catch yourself wondering if I
just had this or that then I would be
happy this by the way is very famous as
as if-then thinking it's amazing how
many people live their whole lives if
then if then if I had this if I could
have that and so on then I would be
happy the truth is fulfilment cannot
always come from material things in fact
easily 85% of fulfilment does not come
from material things it comes from
emotional things it comes from people
and relationships and inner knowledge
and and and so on so fulfilment is a
mindset and happiness is found when you
can reflect and find contentment if you
have to think of one word that's most
important to you that sums you Apple so
it would be like a little beacon table
Ignatian if you want to know what the
most important one word is for Tony
Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey
will.i.am and Howard Schultz I have a
very special secret video for you check
the description for details
[Music]